I don't agree with that.
Then why the fuck did you accept the position!
Who the fuck hired you?!
You should step down!
If that is what you think about  being on [unintelligible] you should step down!
That 2015 confrontation on the Yale campus
between Nicholas Christakis, a sociologist and physician,
and protesting students
was part of a controversy over how to dress up on Halloween.
It all started a week earlier when the school's Intercultural Affairs Council
sent an email encouraging members of the community to be careful
not to offend their fellow students with culturally and racially insensitive costumes.
Christakis' wife Erika, an expert in early childhood education at the university
responded with her own thoughts.
'Is there no room anymore for a child or young person to be a little bit obnoxious...
a little bit inappropriate or provacative or, yes, offensive?'
'American universities' she wrote 'have become places of censure and prohibition.'
Students said that by sending her email
Christakis had failed to create a safe space at Yale's Sillman College,
where she served as associate master.
Nicolas Christakis jumped into the fray,
defending his wife’s email, and then he tried to engage in a dialogue with protestors.
Scenes of students shouting at Christakis, one of Yale’s most respected faculty members, went viral.
Do not interrupt me, I was not angry
and now I want your job to be taken from you.
I don't want you to have this job, I am disgusted knowing that you work at Yale University
where I will get my degree.
Where I will look back and think I have to argue with you.
Don't, no, sir, sir sir don't do it, don't do it-
Christakis not only held onto his tenured professorship
but three years later he was awarded the Sterling Professorship, Yale’s highest faculty honor.
And his confrontation with students kicked off an ongoing national debate about freedom of speech,
political correctness, and Millennial sensitivity on college campuses.
Homophily or the fact that we prefer to connect with people we resemble
have fundamental significance.
As a sociologist, the 56-year-old Christakis is no stranger to highly charged group interactions.
His new book is Blueprint: The Evolutionary Origins of a Good Society,
which argues that our genetic makeup predisposes us to favor  peaceful interaction
and respectful co-existence over angry and violent mob rules.
I have a vision of us as people that actually privileges our common humanity
that is interested not in what is different among us, but what is the same.
I sat down with Christakis to talk about his theory
that what unites us as humans is stronger than what divides us,
the power of evolution as an explanatory system for society
and whether enlightenment values
such as civil discourse and intellectual freedom are still respected in our nation's colleges and universities.